me
re
[音楽]
あのスライドにメールあの羊ですあの巨すみませんあの羊と
大好きな羊と喧嘩をしましてちょっと足を悪くしてしまったので座りながら進めさせて
いただきたいと思います
よろしくお願い致します
えっと私のお仕事なんですけれども
酪農教育ファーム走りデータと言います
ファシリテーターというのを辞書で引きますと調整役という風な
ことで私の場合は牧場に来ていただける方とその動物の間を調整するお仕事をさせて
いただいています
えっと今ではへ
子どもたちの教育の現場で
牧場の多面的な機能を利用させていただいて
食育のお話はもちろんですし
人間の子供たちの成長と動物たちの成長を併せ持った
心と体の成長のちょっとデリケートなお話なんかを牧場のおじさん風に
アレンジしてお話をさせていただいています
私がどうしてこのようなお仕事に就いた母ということを少しだけお話しさせてください
私は神奈川県で生まれました割と東海なところですごく自然に憧れていました
そして両親が17歳私が高校2年生の時ですね
ちょっと離婚をしてしまいましたねそれがきっかけで私はもう一人で外国に行こうか
などで暮らそうと
決断しました19歳の時に単身カナダに行きました
そして
ためたアルバイト代でまずついたかんだでへ
大陸横断バスというのが向こうには走っているんですけれども
グレイハウンドバスというバスのターミナルでバックパッカーのようにして過ごし
少し日々を過ごすんですけれどもやっぱりお腹が過ぎてスーパーに行きました
で初めてのスーパーでの衝撃的な事件が起きたんですね
自分で簡単に食べられるご飯をカゴに詰めてレジカウンターに並びました
そうするとブツブツ言った年配の男性が私のところに近づいてきて私のハーブをパワー
アンプ全部蹴っ飛ばすですね
ねカシャカシャカシャっとこうなると a 腰に鉄砲をつけた
警備の方グワーッと集まって海外になっちゃったんですね
で
不言葉があまりわからなかったので指差す方の例字カウンターに私はすっとこう並び
直したんですね
そこのレジの並んでいる方々をよく見ると黒人の方であったり
アジア系の方であったり
ネイティブの方があったりして
a その0時で働く方を黒人の女性でした
つまりは
義手差別だったんですね出始めていた
スーパーねー
そういったショッキングなことを受けてしまって
私自身はすごくあの
強くなりました
スーパーも強い
レストランも強い
なんかみんな町が全部強くなっちゃったんですね
ですけどお腹は空くんです
そんな時に
バスのターミナルにも本当のホームレスさんもいらっしゃってですね
ホームレスさんが時々列を作って並んでいることがあるんですね
勇気を持って話しかけてみるとみんなでご飯を食べに行くって言うんですね
ごはんが食べるんだった僕もついていこうと思ってついていったら
その先は教会でした
その評価委で
教会の清掃活動をすると最後にパンとスープが食べられるような仕組みがあって
何度かそこでお世話になりました
そんな仕事というかそんな暮らしをしている中でへ
1人の男性に会うことがありましたん
田舎に来て農場で仕事をしたらご飯が食えるぞ
これはもう行くしかないと思いました
自然のカナダで動物が触れて仕事がしたらご飯が食べられる
これはいくしかない迷わず極上に入って
いろいろ頭世話になりました
牧場ではここからが私の動物を
との暮らしが始まるんですけども牧場の暮らしは
まあ牛の尾さんを手伝うこともあれば馬の調教することもあって
羊の毛刈りも空いた時間でしなければならないし
やはりとやられることを言葉がわからないながらにも教えてくださいました
そして牧場のまぁいつものお仕事朝は
牛を牛舎から外に出すようなお仕事があるんですけれども
大きな牛を全く慣れてない私が出すのはすごく難しいことだったりもしたんですけれど
も
仕事をしていく中で
そこにいる講師を上手に
使うことでへ
親たちが
それにつれて出てきてくれることだとか
あとは馬の蹄鉄を付け替えるときなんかのは
へ
すごく暴れる馬がたくさんいるんですね
なんですけれども力ずくで抑えるよりその横にそっと
肛門を連れてきてあげることで馬が落ち着いたりすることがあります
そんな風にして少しずつ動物の扱いに慣れたりしました
大きなお家薄いというのはやっぱり警戒心をすごく持っていて
何かしようと思うとやはり壁があります
ですけれどもそのお母さんの大事にしている講師を私が卒倒
大切に扱うことで
お母さんの警戒心がいくらか解かれます
そしてそれを繰り返しているうちになんとなく信頼関係が生まれるようになるんですね
その動物との信頼関係などというものは私に声をかけてくれた農場の子さんとの関係に
も結びつきます
の所主さんは動物たちを大切にしていて私に教えてくれた技術で私が動物たちを大切に
扱う
そうするとどうの中主さんは私自身を今度
大事に扱ってくれるようにつながるんですね
言葉が通じない中でも自分のできることとできないこと
それをオープンにしていくことで
信頼関係が結ばされるということを感じました
自分がオープンにあることは
その方に対しての信頼感を作ります
そんな風にして
私はその自分の得意なことを
することで
いろんな方との信頼関係を結ぶということを
カナダで学び
そして自分の得意なことを活かしてつける仕事に就きたくて
日本に帰ってからは
楽のファーム走りデーターというのになりました
そしてこれろうそくですファシリテーターの仕事の中でへ
よく一番よくお話しするストーリーをちょっと話させてください
ろうそくです皆さんの中にも1本のろうそくが
と思っていますお父さんとお母さんからもらった大事なろうそくです
そして動物たちの中にも大事なろうそくが
と思っていますそしてこの日が消えてしまうことはあるんですね
しょうがないんです消えてしまうことを
ですけどその火が消えないようにろうそくは縮んでくるんですけれども
どこかでその労を
足さなければならないんですね
その方法というのは私たちが動物であったり植物であったり
彼らの燃えてるろうそくを途中でふっと吹き消して
そして残っているローを私たちのろうそくにすぎ+んですね
食事です
命をいただいています
そんな話をさせていただきます
またその暮らしている中ではそのロウソクの火というのが消えてしまうばかりでなく
困難というような
大きな風が吹いた時に少し路側がよまることがあります
ですけどこの困難というものは自分の得意なことだとかで殺陣をつくって
へ守ることができます
私ごとで恥ずかしいんですけども
足を怪我したのは7月でした
このケガをしてからですねなんと仕事を失ってしまいました
おまけにですね
実は家族も失ってしまったということなんですけれども
しかし
得意なことを一生懸命やることでその困難という
風が吹いたとしても
気が消えずに守ることができます
一緒に仕事をしていたみんなが
これからも一緒にやろうと言ってくれたりだとか
あとは
いろんな活動をしている牧場があったのは長沼町というところで
そこでのまちづくりをしている皆と一緒に新しいことをしようとか
あとは余市町の方でサステイナブルな暮らしを目指している
エコビレッジのメンバーだとかあと新しい牧場を作るようにてザってくれたとかそう
いう言葉を自分の得意なところで
いただいたりしています
こちらのスライドはえっと冷蔵庫の中のちょっと残った食材なんです
これはフードロスにつながってしまうものでそのフードロスをなくそうという取り組み
をしてサルベージパーティという
方との活動が
こんな食材をみんなで持ち寄りながらこんなご飯をつくって一緒に皆で幸せな時間を
過ごしたりします
皆さんどうか得意なことを思って
誰かの
盾を作ってあげてください
自信を持って自分のできること得意なことをしてください
得意なことを立てを作る方法
いろいろあります a まずはその大事な人の盾を作るにその大事な人と一緒に食事を
してください
ごはんを食べてください命をいただいてください
そしてお腹が膨れると人は自然とオープンになれます
そういった中で大事な人の
価値観
こころのものさしをそっと聞いてあげてください
その方に彼が大事にしているもの
何か物質的な物を大事にしている人もいれば何かすることを大事にしている人もいます
し
自分だけの時間を大切にしてたりして
人それぞれ大事にしているものというのはあった口がいます
自分の物差しを決して出さず
その大事な形の物差しを外だけ聞いてあげてください
その
大事なものを
お互い確かめるというのは
同じ生きている者同士が
いるこのような中に支え合う世の中にへ
つながる第一歩ではないでしょうか
大事な人の大事な物を大切にするということ
そんなに大きな組織が大きな目標を掲げつ取り組むようなことではありません
小さな小さなことです
一人一人が少しだけ心をかけるだけで
いろんな事が
うまくいく
おまじないのような
アイディアです
皆さんどうぞ取り組んでてください
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
[拍手]